turning to afghanistan mr speaker
it's been a disastrous week
an unfolding tragedy
20 years ago
the taliban were largely in control of
afghanistan
al-qaeda were using the country as a
training ground
and a base for terror including plotting
the horrific 9 11 attack
there were widespread human rights
abuses
girls were denied an education women
couldn't work
being gay was punishable by death
all imposed
without democracy
since then a fragile democracy emerged
mr speaker it was by no means perfect
but no international terrorist attacks
have been mounted from afghanistan in
that period
women have gained liberty and one office
schools and clinics have been built
and afghans have allowed themselves to
dream of a better future
mr speaker those achievements were born
of sacrifice
sacrificed by the afghan people
who bravely fought alongside their nato
allies
and british sacrifice
over 150 000 uk personnel have served in
afghanistan
including members
across this house
including the honorable and gallant
members
for tumbridge and mauling
the barnsley central
plymouth moor view
norwich south
aldershot
the isle of wight
filton and bradley stoke and wells
they and the tens of thousands of others
deployed in afghanistan served in
difficult and challenging circumstances
and the labour party and i'm sure
everybody across this house thanks each
and every one of them of the 150 000
many returned with life-changing
injuries
and tragically
didn't return
at all
i'll just make progress then i will
i will
later today i'll be attending the
service at raf linen outside role in
basset to commemorate the 10th
anniversary of calls today of the last
repatriation through bad basset and will
my wilderness agree with me that the
message to those people that i will see
today must be not that these young lives
were wasted whether they played an
absolutely essential role in deterring
and destroying terrorism and count
similar good works in afghanistan
i wholeheartedly agree with that we'll
address it in just one moment thank you
mr speaker for many of those who
returned from afghanistan and other
places around the world
mental health has been an all too
familiar issue raised by veterans time
and again
and the events of the last few days and
weeks will have exacerbated the
situation reopening old wounds and
everybody across this house will have
had examples of that
so we must improve
mental health services for our veterans
mr speaker and addressing the very point
that's just been made i want to address
directly all those who served in
afghanistan
and their families
especially the families of those who
were lost
your sacrifice was not in vain
you brought stability
reduced the terrorist threat
and enabled progress
we are all proud of what you did
your sacrifice deserves better than this
and so do the afghan people
mr speaker there's been a major
miscalculation of the resilience of the
afghan forces
and staggering complacency from our
government about the taliban threat
the result
is that the taliban are not backing
control of afghanistan
the gains made through 20 years of
sacrifice hang precariously
women and girls fear for their liberty
afghan civilians are holding on to the
undercarriage of nato aircraft literally
clinging
to departing hope
and we face new threats to our security
and an appalling humanitarian crisis i
will
hopefully right honourable gentleman for
all the reasons he mentioned doesn't he
agree that president biden is actually
wrong when he talks about american
sacrifices in a civil war the taliban is
not at war with a regime the taliban is
at war with the civilized values of
justice equality and tolerance that all
of us hold dear and against which it
respects no international boundaries
i would agree with that intervention and
thank the honourable member for it
mr speaker i'll just make some progress
then of course
mr speaker the desperate situation
requires
and for the prime minister to snap out
of his complacency
the most urgent task
the most urgent task is the protection
of our diplomatic staff still working
here in kabul
and the evacuation of british nationals
and afghans who've risked their lives
mr speaker let me be clear the labour
party fully supports the deployment of
troops to this end
we want it to succeed just as quickly
and safely as possible
the defense secretary said
that some people who've worked with us
will not get back
unconscionable
the government in one moment i will
the government must outline a plan
to work with our allies to do everything
that's possible to ensure that does not
happen
guarantee that our troops have the
resources they need to carry out their
mission effectively and as safely as
possible and work to provide
stable security at the airport in kabul
so flights can depart and visas can be
processed we all know how difficult that
is we all know how hard everybody is
working on the ground and we fully
supported and i've raised an issue
not by way of criticism but just
to get some reassurance because there
are reports this morning from ngos
that an evacuate evacuation plan left
almost empty this morning because
evacuees couldn't get to the airport um
to get to that plane as i say we are not
challenging the work on the ground we
know how difficult it is but at some
appropriate moment i would like to see
that um addressed um if if if true
i will yes
i'm grateful to the writer general for
giving away can i just bring him back
to uh the statement by the president of
the united states the other day does he
not agree with me uh that this took on
the terms really of a sort of shameful
excuse
when he blames the afghan armed forces
who have lost nearly 70 000 in trying to
defend afghan when corruption had
stripped away much of their pay their
money their support and the american
decision to withdraw
the aircraft cover was almost certainly
going to lead us does he not think that
that is shameful
mr speaker the u.s is of course an
important ally but to overlook the
fighting of the afghan troops and forces
in recent years they have been at the
forefront of that fighting i think is
wrong
for any of us to overlook or the
situation that they now find themselves
in
mr speaker
the urgent task is of course the
evacuation equally urgent is the
immediate refugee crisis i'll just make
some progress than i will
many afghans have bravely sought to
rebuild their country
they did so on a promise
of democratic freedoms
the rule of law
and liberty for the oppressed including
women and girls
they are our friends
and that was our promise
they are now fearing for their lives
we do not turn our backs on friends at
their time of need we owe an obligation
to the people of afghanistan
there should be a resettlement scheme
for people to rebuild their lives here
safe and legal routes
it must be a resettlement scheme that
meets the scale of the enormous
challenge
but what the government has announced
this morning does not do that
it is vague
it will support just 5 000 in the first
year a number without rationale was that
based on a risk assessment of those most
at need or was it plucked out of the air
others
the offer to others the offer to others
in one moment
the offer to others is in the long term
in the long term but for those
desperately needing our help now there
is no long term mr speaker
just day-to-day survival
yet again
this government i will give away
i'm very grateful to him for giving way
as well as the need for a much more bold
and ambitious resettlement program would
you agree with me that this disaster
must mark a turning point for our failed
asylum system in particular getting rid
of the so-called hostile environment and
the nationality and borders bill under
which a woman fleeing the taliban with
her children on a boat across the
channel would be criminalized does he
agree that that bill must now be revised
uh thank you for that intervention i'm
going to come on to the specifics of the
system
because yet again
this government seems ill-prepared and
unwilling just as it has been too slow
to provide sanctuary to afghans who
served alongside britain too many
reports of eligible afghans facing
bureaucratic hurdles and too many
unfairly excluded
mr speaker knowing the date of
withdrawal was coming for months
the home office is not close to
completing the process they've already
got up and running
it was designed to help 7 000 people
yet home office
figures this week
showed only 2 000 have been helped so
far i will be playing
i thank my honourable friend for uh
giving way and the point that i wanted
to make indeed to the prime minister was
the situation facing afghan sikhs now i
know from my own constituency casework
that there are afghan seats in the
system at the moment waiting for
clearance from the home office so one of
the things i would like to call on the
government to do is to process those as
quickly as possible and not leave all
those people in the system waiting any
longer than they have to at the moment
they are terrified of the idea of being
sent back home and despite the
reassurance given to my honourable
friend i do not see any movement from
the home office to give these people the
legal status that they need
i'm grateful for that intervention and
there have been other examples across
the house of uh individuals and groups
who are very obviously at risk in
afghanistan and need to come out just as
quickly as possible and that's mr
speaker where the question arises to
what's behind the 5000 number and why
the others are having to wait so long
mr speaker the scale of the refugee
crisis requires an international
response but we must lead it
and lead with a resettlement program
that meets the scale of the challenge
the scheme must be generous and
welcoming
if it's not
we know the consequences
we know the consequences now
violent reprisals in
afghanistan people tragically fleeing
into the arms of human traffickers we
know this is what will happen
more people risking and losing their
lives on unsafe journeys
including a class across the english
channel
we cannot betray
our friends we must lead i will
uh for him giving way
he speaks of people fleeing but what we
have yet to assess is whether anyone
outside of kabul is able to get to
somewhere of safety does he agree that
now a safe corridor needs to be opened
to an international border so that those
who are not near kabul can also get to
safety via third countries yeah
i'm grateful for that
i'm grateful for that intervention
and there is huge concern as all members
will know about um our line of sight
beyond kabul just at the moment and
again that calls into question where the
5 000 number comes from
because we're not even in a position to
assess at the moment the position
outside of kabul
we cannot betray our friends
we must lead
mr speaker mr i will
the government of this kingdom to be
overthrown by a wicked and brutal regime
i venture that he would want a leading
role in the resistance he wouldn't be
queuing at the airport would he
[Music]
when i was director of public
prosecutions
i had some of my prosecutors in
afghanistan at huge risk
working on counterterrorism with other
brave souls there so i won't take that
from him or anybody else
[Applause]
mr speaker once these immediate
challenges are addressed
we face an uncertain and difficult
future the taliban are back in control
and we cannot be naive about the
consequences
we've lost our primary source of
leverage in political discussions
and everything we've lost we everything
we've achieved in the last 20 years is
now under threat
i go to make some progress and then i
will give way
mr speaker the prime minister is right
to say that we cannot allow afghanistan
to become a training ground for violent
hate and terrorism
but that will be more difficult now that
afghanistan has descended into chaos
but if preventing al qaeda camps is now
the limit of our ambition
we are betraying 20 years of sacrifice
by our armed forces
and we're betraying the afghan people
who cannot be left to the cruelty of the
taliban i will i'm very grateful to my
writerable friend for giving way
he speaks about the lack of ambition and
the lack of urgency which of course
summarizes everything about this
government's approach to this crisis and
many others
isn't it telling about the whole
approach of this government that when we
had an afghan government that we wanted
to support they should cut the amount of
overseas aid we sent and now the taliban
are in charge they're talking about
increasing the amount of oversight he's
aid
i'm grateful for that intervention i'm
going to come to the question of aid in
just a minute because it's a very
important point in this
context looking at what has happened in
recent weeks and months i'm going to
make some progress and then i will
make way
so we have to use every tool that
remains at our disposal to protect human
rights in afghanistan
the government is right not to recognize
the taliban as the official government
the prime minister's made that clear but
this must be part of a wider strategy
developed with our un security partners
our nato allies
to apply pressure to the taliban not
only to stamp out a resurgence of terror
groups
but to retain the liberties and human
rights of afghans we must work with
afghans neighbors to ensure there is
consistent pressure
and there must be a u.n backed plan to
ensure our aid budget is used to support
humanitarian causes in afghanistan not
fund the taliban
mr speaker
this is a difficult task
with no guarantee of success
so it should concern us all that the
prime minister's judgment on afghanistan
has been appalling
mr speaker
nobody believes that britain and our
allies could have remained in
afghanistan indefinitely
all that britain could have fought alone
nato leaders were put nato leaders were
put in a difficult position
after president trump agreed with the
taliban that all u.s forces would
withdraw by may 2021
but mr speaker that agreement was made
in february 2020
18 months ago
we've had 18 months to prepare and plan
for the consequences of what followed
to plan and to prepare
for this resettlement
of refugees and those that have
supported us
for supporting the afghan government in
managing withdrawal
for securing international and regional
pressure on the taliban and support for
the afghan government the very problems
we're confronting today in this debate
were all known problems the last 18
months and has been a failure of
preparation
mr speaker
the lack of planning is
unforgivable
and the prime minister bears a heavy
responsibility
mr speaker he mutters today he was in a
position to lead
but he didn't
britain britain holds a seat at the
united nations security council we're a
key player within nato we're chair of
the g7
everyone every one of these platforms
could and should have been used to
prepare for the withdrawal of forces
to rally international support behind a
plan to stabilize afghanistan through
the process and keep us safe i will give
way in just a minute
but what did the
mr speaker
did the prime minister use those
platforms in those 18 months to prepare
no he did
what did he do
what did he do instead
[Music]
we debated this
he cut the development budget he cut the
development budget
that was key to the strength and
resilience of democracy in afghanistan
he's making great deal today of the
money he's putting in
292 million pounds was spent in
afghanistan in 2019
in 2021 155 million short-sighted
small-minded and a threat to security
[Applause]
i will in a moment are going to make
this list
he failed to visit afghanistan as prime
minister
meaning that his last trip his last trip
as foreign secretary in 2018 was not to
learn
or to push british interests
but to avoid a vote on heathrow
[Applause]
hundreds of thousands of british people
have flown to afghanistan to serve the
prime minister flew to avoid public
service
mr speaker the list goes on
in march this year the prime minister
published an integrated review of
security defense development and foreign
policy
huge review he boasted
that the review would in his words
demonstrate to our allies
in europe and beyond
that they can always count on the uk
when it really matters
well the afghan government was an ally
yet in the integrated review
there were just two passing references
to afghanistan
two passing references
mr speaker the review didn't even
mention the taliban
it didn't even mention the taliban it
didn't mention nato withdrawal or the
consequences of the doha agreement
it did cut the size of the army and we
did criticize it at the time
the very force that we're now relying on
i off the ball
astonishingly careless you were probably
on holiday
the question is why was the prime
minister so careless why did he fail to
lead
mr speaker it comes down to complacency
and poor judgment
there was a calculation i will in a
moment i'm going to make this case there
was a calculation that withdrawal would
lead to military stalemate in
afghanistan and that stalemate would
accelerate political discussions
seeing this in july
members on both sides of this house
warned the government read hansard that
they may be underestimating the threat
of the taliban on both sides of the
house that point was made that was
ignored
and the government's preparation for
withdrawal were based on a
miscalculation of the resilience of the
afghan forces and a staggering
complacency about the taliban threat
the prime minister is as guilty as
anyone this sunday
this sunday he said this and i quote
we've known for a long time
that this was the way things were going
what he said on sunday
that's not what he told this house
that's not what he told this house in
july
the prime minister stood there and
assured members that
there is no military path to victory for
the taliban
and then and then he went on to say mr
speaker i do not think that the taliban
are capable of victory by military means
the british government were wrong and
complacent the prime minister was wrong
and complacent and when he wasn't
rewriting history
the prime minister was displaying the
same appalling judgment and complacency
last week
mr speaker the response of the british
ambassador
to the taliban arriving at the gates of
kabul
was to personally process the paperwork
for those that needed to flee
he is still there
and we thank him and his staff
[Music]
the prime minister of
the prime minister's response to the
taliban arriving at the gates of kabul
was to go on holiday
no sense of the gravity of the situation
not leadership to drive international
efforts on the evacuation
the foreign secretary shakes his head
mr speaker
what would what would i do differently i
wouldn't stay on holiday
whilst kabul was falling
and there are numerous examples
of those leaders on both sides of the
house who've come back immediately in a
time of crisis the foreign secretary
stayed on this he's shouting now he's
shouting now
the prime minister was heard and i want
to hear the leader of the opposition i
don't want people
you may disagree but you also may wish
to catch my eye don't ruin that chance
here's statement
mr speaker the foreign secretary shouts
now but he stayed on holiday while our
missionary
in afghanistan was disintegrated
mr speaker
he didn't even speak
to ambassadors in the region as kabul as
kabul fell to the taliban
let that sink in
you cannot coordinate an international
response from the beach
[Music]
a dereliction of duty by the prime
minister and the foreign secretary
a government totally unprepared for the
scenario that it had 18 months to
prepare for
mr speaker
it's one thing for people to lose trust
in the prime minister at home
but when the trust in the word of our
prime minister is questioned abroad
there are serious consequences for our
safety and security at home
mr speaker in one moment
recent events in afghanistan shame the
west
not just the scenes of chaos
but what it says about our abandonment
of the afghan people
for those brave people around the world
living under regimes paying scant regard
to human rights but resisting those
regimes in pursuit of democracy equality
and individual freedom what does this
say to them
what does this retreat from freedom
signal to those prepared to stand up for
it
what does this surrender to extremism
mean for those prepared to face it down
and what does it mean
for those nations who support an
international rules-based system
when we hand over power to those who
recognize no rules at all that is the
challenge of our time
mr speaker
the british and afghan people will have
to live with the consequences of the
prime minister's failure
we have fought for 20 years to read
afghanistan of terror
terror which threatens our security here
in britain and liberty in afghanistan
the taliban are back in control
the prime minister has no plan how to
handle the situation just as he had no
plan to prevent it
what we've won through 20 years of
sacrifice
could all be lost that is the cost mr
speaker of careless leadership